okay less than 597 gladiator 1775
average rating time handicapped 30
minutes of craziness let's go efore each
poor [ __ ] poor what a start
each poor what is that age for oh it's a
thinker uh-oh bad news right around the
corner
where is it I was ready to trade let's
do that I was ready to trade and then
give a queen check here or something
that's what I had up my sleeve here I
didn't want to do this cuz my bishops
kind of dead let's do this watch over
this square let's get this structure now
this Knight is in trouble
it's out of play
maid threat Forks there is a knight move
here now right here hitting the Queen
but I think I still have it okay let's
just go with the Queen trade or
development night out other night out
get castle no matter what okay I had
this Square covered throw in a check
just to burn time actually I'm grabbing
that Knight now I'm sure there's like
four people who already have a win I
already have a win there all right just
follow up have my pawn here watch over
my Bishop and then I can move my rook
maybe even push again get rid of that
dark square Bishop so I could push that
pond to victory lane victory lane where
is it less than seven I'm just gonna
throw in two time burner
okay anything anything no time no time
no time
okay back to tournament - okay there's a
bunch of two's everybody has to up there
all right still very early less than 28
minutes remaining less than 28 all right
I'd have to say it's implied it's
implied the FP I'm gonna have to start
to abbreviate go with the FP the FP is
still available maybe okay let's do this
all right let's get more development in
Castle I have this half open def file
that Bishop al Castle no fishing pole I
guess with that move it's a pretty much
saying there's no fishing pole get rid
of that dark square Bishop and then play
here because that Bishop is on my night
Wow
autumn is mouse-clicks as usual well I
got that night don't
okay this is a what do you call this how
this pressure on G - you call this
pressure on G - right here okay we call
this f3 f3 take that Bishop and I have
the Queen very very serious threats I'm
on the Queen pawn push looking for
checkmate get that Queen out of there
what do I let's defend that bishop a
little bit there's the main there had to
have been a maid there king over now
okay double checks I only have 10
seconds what am i doing there in check
what are they gonna do they're gonna
block what they're clean to have - oh I
got the clean get over here get over
here good move move move ah
come on right here
anything anything anything pawn push
anything I just want to take pieces run
run run run run run run run anything
anything got a premium with everything
checks gonna time oh they're down on
time why did that get so close the
wolfman the big the bad okay we'll be
twenty five is the big bad wolf is not
moving here uh he might have
disconnected he's not um he's not one to
just do this we've played many times
he's just he's not moving maybe there's
a connection issues
all righty yeah let's see okay well I'm
gonna promote not a Rick move Wow love
my mouth oh yes he did resign no he
didn't resign he did disconnect you
can't see it on the stream just above
this you might be able to see the shadow
of it or something a little balloon that
pops up in 18 seconds
I should be getting the W unless they
have to consult with the with what with
the server the Fonzie Oh No
might turn out to be the Fonzie gambit
or something who was here for the farm Z
ok give me the W ok back to tournament I
got plus three out of that twelve ten
nine I'm in third I gotta go quicker
definitely have to go quicker I don't
know where all that time went lower step
we're a step in this direction you know
it I'm still gonna is clearly sniffing
out any any fishing pole nonsense where
are they oh they're fearing it you're
fearing the fish fear the fish night
here move night you know you want to
move power of suggestion yes h2 back to
tournament fishing pole engaged 19 17 12
12 10 max is up there was having a good
tournament 5 out of 5 1882 player very
good very good so far 5 out of 5 all
right are they gonna pair me up what's
going on here
there's a hundred nine players there's
got to be somebody available to play
here we go
efore don't drop pieces no I was I was
thinking for a second this was the guy
that I dropped that minor piece against
and then uh somehow came back queen h4
f5 Bishop h6 backup
let's get up 5min oh let's do it anyhow
let's go for it I wanna get my knight
here they're probably gonna take my
night out they get this pawn though well
I should have done that maybe uh oh oh
Knight here oh no no no no no oh no say
isn't so I'm a dead man
I gotta give up my clean ah man man man
man you could do it you could do it you
could do it hit the Queen hit the Queen
hit the Queen hit right here mate threat
made threat mates right I got the Queen
back it's me oh oh that was so dark
calculated I would have take it though
I'm gonna take it even if it wasn't
calculated 27 18 13 12 12 why did I have
to drop my Queen like that you got lucky
again
Wow there was an hair give me the points
if there's gonna be errors they're not
giving me points what's going on here
okay let's go
is there something going messy here
oh this isn't pairing me up what's
happening here what's happening am I the
only one I'm not seeing no I got 33 they
did give me points for that give me
those points I might get some more free
points because this is maybe another err
oh something's going something's going
wrong am I the only one
hi what's the scoop somebody saying my
time is messed up somebody saying I want
a game and it counted as a lot oh this
guys having a bad day oh man
that's a bad day when you have this
happening to you I want a game and it
count as a loss Oh guess who might get
first might get first right here Oh what
what a finish this might be Oh
everybody might be getting points just
by Ayers alone another heir boosted up
here
I got plus six it's just gonna end this
way
I have a lead I have a lead I have a
lead here you notice I'm tongue-tied if
there's no game going on I have no idea
what to say I just reflect on these
numbers I see the numbers up top here
and I just call them out as I see him
and I look at the chat here I go I go
fishing for interesting words I got
fishing for interesting words here
there's buggy there's flag this guy
right here I can't get over that one I
haven't experienced that one yet I did
experience though oh we got Owens back
in action here double those points they
got their stuff back together okay Alpen
variation quit your talk and get playing
now get playing here al pijn ah that's
the name of it right yes let's get that
Bishop out there easy does it here easy
does it get that e6 in 86 let's go get
your pieces out let's go let's roll pawn
push the Queen runs away a little scared
I'm going to take right now and then Oh
by getting a free pawn here free pawn
I'm not gonna take them I want
development I might have some fishing
stuff coming up here I don't come over
here
clean check no I haven't covered I don't
want to take that pond I was a fearful
of like rook there and that sort of
stuff let's go here quit trying to get
that fishing pole in there although it
might have been might have had it
somehow no not really there's like a
Bishop f4 at the end of it to defend
let's come back I don't have very I
don't have much time get out of there
Knight my bishop wants to go to this
square now pinpoint come on move let's
go I have this hit okay catching up on
time let's get rid of that Bishop get
rid of this Knight
okay okay let's take him Queen Esther
recapture all right let's just do this
less than ten less than ten watch out
for the mates grab a pond grab a pond
whoa don't let's just do this
seven seconds pre-move time time burners
time burners this is another pre-move
they got my pond okay let's take here
let's go here where it's nice and cozy
throw in a check come back throw in
another check on the h-file even if they
see it back to tournament 51 so we had a
little bit of a speed bump right there
with the tournament everybody was not
able to get a game in oh we got games
though they are back fired up here so we
got Joe Joe Grimm alright let's go and
play a good game against Joe here I
should have maybe reinforced my e4 point
let's watch over this and also night
before I want to keep my bishop right
here castle here it is sneaky sneaky h7
it's happening
again Go Fish it's the go fish line it's
happening again
clean h5 is the follow-up no good
solution
this is TKO land that's me age 7 back to
tournament 65 35 31 30 okay 16 minutes
and change remaining okay click down the
dice you are doubling the points so if
you win you get twice as many as you're
twice as many points compared to if you
didn't click ok let's go I not be 5 ok I
can't be playing there now so let's get
b5 in Bishop d7 knight c6 no it's a fork
I don't get this though bishop just
comes back that wasn't a good idea by me
let's get this night out of here where's
it gonna go Bishop here and then just
castle mmm take care take care Knight
goes here I back up whoa it's a little
scary come back oh there's Bishop takes
pawn there is Bishop takes pawn and it's
gonna look ugly but I'm gonna do this
just so I have a little shelter I need
some shelter
give me some shelter Queen even though
it's a just two minor pieces I could
have taken the rook I just want a
shelter the night plays here maybe no
the rook took oh they're down on time my
queen has been lost again night here
sack on this square something seems
juicy let's go here development they
don't have time out of time no time
let's kill that bishop
or just go there anyhow with the check
they're down on time don't check the
server back to turn it
uh what's going on here 81 and then 40s
next one let's get this H pot in the mix
these are not good ideas to be going
with in our slow games by the way these
are just taking to account sneaky stuff
here trying to be sneaky and get some
quick wins in there let's kick that
bishop around that's got to be pretty
uncomfortable it's got to go back home
pawn push here I like my LightSquared
Bishop now I'll give them up and then
hopefully this guy doesn't get active I
think a6 is a good spot here we go
get out of there night I don't want him
on those squares that's good on this
right here it's all stop stopping the
students the Rockets on the B file and
having the bishop Fein keto can't be too
bad can it
it's Castle I have to watch out for
Bishop here okay I'm on the clean I
don't want to be on the Queen here
alright let's let's get that clean pawn
push Knight right here ah okay well am i
doing get this pawn up I just want to
take care I just don't want to deal with
that I want to just push this pawn if
the bishop plays here I kick it away
making one threat alright let's stop
that light square Bishop from getting
active right here rook takes pawn is a
threat
it takes pawn oh oh right here pig it's
a pig it's a pig I really just want to
take that let's just back up right here
where where where right here right here
my rook is um I only have 7 seconds
how much time 7 seconds uh get here
quick Queen trade no no no no no you
can't what's going on here what's that
Queen doing what's she doing mate
threats oh no no no no no no no 2.4
Oh barely barely no no no okay got it
I have it I have it oh man you have no
idea man if I had um oh man my blood
pressures going through the roof
my heart is pounding no it's only a game
Wow I don't know it gets intense for me
I don't know I guess maybe you have to
just take my word for it
um they were thrown in those time
burners that was not cool
I'm only supposed to do that don't do
that to me 99 all right this guy's a non
mover no he is a mover he's not up okay
the points are doubled get d5 in maybe
be five with the tempo here we go be
five I could trap the bishop maybe let's
do this break up in that oh oh oh move
it too fast
get out of there tonight I do not want
to deal with you on my side of the board
grab that pond yeah my other night
around development development
recaptured the bishop then I could
follow up with this move or just play
here for right now hon push there we go
let's go more trades
get out of there they're trying to be
sneaky on h7 I'm on the Queen they
missed it they're gonna resign they
resigned back to tournament 73 is in
second mini chess all right and others
are resigning that's just extending the
lead toad aerobic the last time he had a
disconnection issued any is a suffering
from disconnection issues all right
all right let's get the bishop out well
not here is maybe uh not too far off
okay I should forget about that look
here let's go here I'm on g2 I don't
know if I want to take it though let's
come back here what am i doing
just move already oh yeah you want to
retreat don't you that's just a
wonderful spot isn't it
okay well I'm push pump push d5 what are
you waiting for get d5 in Bishop takes
pawn does not work
get out of there Queen cannot deal with
that
get over here twenty-four ticks I can't
move that night the ah what are they
doing to me here get out of there just
not here I just chased that night away
to ask where I wanted to go to that is
what you don't want to do I feel like
I'm gonna fall for me
I can't move my knight come on over here
Queen Defense stuff please over here
Knight right here I think come of that
now Queen takes I got the Queen okay
let's get this now let's do this get
that dark square Bishop out of here get
rid of one of the bishops oh they missed
it less than 10 though I got a rook I
got a rook what's going on to get the
bishop well they got a pan they got a
pin they got a pin they not doing that I
can't move come on come on come on come
on come on come on whoa that's too much
too many pieces give a check they're
flying why are they flying I should have
taken the bishop I should have taken the
bishop again I'll take it now come on
don't
Oh donut I'm in the other pod
oh the wolf got me why the wolf have to
get me ah man
ah was he flying or what I should have
had that there's no excuses quit making
excuses you should win that ah
why did you have to lose that one ah
they just had a silly pun oh they just
had a silly pun and that's all they need
it because that's what you call what
they had mating material didn't they man
I want to cry after that one I really do
you might think I'm joking but I'm not
and if you don't get your act together
you know what's gonna happen you're
gonna go down in flames again you're
gonna go down in flames again the brook
is gonna be right here it's a giant pig
okay defend here what am i doing
this pond is falling ah why'd I have to
lose that one the rook can play here now
oh I just dropped a rook please don't
take it please
oh they took it
please say it's gonna be okay still I'm
on tilt I'm clearly on tilt right now I
got the rook hang on hang on I should
have kept my tricky night around oh hang
on hang on hang on my rook is active
activity activity King position King
position stop the knight from getting
excited stop the knife from getting
excited I have no idea what that really
means watch out for the tricks no I need
to hang onto a time burner that's the
last time Bernie that I have they
expected to recapture don't do it King
here you know you want to do King there
it'll be me five come on come on go go
go go go grab a pawn push up on push up
on again grab a knight I got a queen I
got the rook time burners I don't I'm
not can't move fast
there's Forks and everything how many
Forks am I gonna miss just gotta run my
king they're flying
oh that's at least a draw-game drop and
like
second place is catching up oh no no no
no and I could hear it already or
something probably oh he's doing it to
make it look close or something no I'm
not know this much I want to win every
game I want to win every game I'm not
throwing games here I don't know if
that's being typed in the chat but I
have I was my sixth sense is kicking in
he's trying to make it exciting I see
his tricks no I want to win every game
so what do you do you regroup stay
focused now there's no time to be
getting scared
grab this pawn grab this pond and they
get here for a deadly mate whoa what's
going on here what is going on okay
let's get here let's kill this night
here pin the night hit the night hit
that night they're not moving uh let's
hit the night I was gonna take here I
was afraid of clean stuff oh wow okay
I'm gonna play here cuz I have a night
oh but there's a queen check right here
was that scary I gotta play the f8 no
it's not scary anymore I have this
there's Forks but I have a lot of
material no no I actually I have that
covered I had that one covered I have
this room covered too a lot of stuff is
covered less than five okay where's the
main
right here I'm gonna take that part
making one threat pawn takes our mate
until very very close to me back to
tournament 127 109 no 147 four minutes
four minutes remain less than four
minutes remaining
oh we got resigner 's designers okay if
it was closer there's no way that I
would be in first right now there's no
way no way with that loss and then a
draw back to back I went in Reverse
right there and this one is not paring
things up here three minutes and change
three minutes it's not happening where's
this guy in second place okay there's
still a bit off
three minutes in change they're not
pairing me up I'll get some points for
this I guess what I really just give me
some points err I'll jump up anyhow
while we're waiting hello on the chat
feel free to connect if you haven't
already could follow on Twitter or on
Facebook I posted that link and there
are other spots but those are two
popular ones err it's close 167 129 116
there's only enough time for one more
game at least one more game maybe two
okay grab that pond right here let's do
this get this pond up here kick that
night away first and then do this now
it's very uncomfortable isn't it
let's keep this structure space on both
in the center right here whoa who's
looking for tricks now black is looking
for tricks all right let's take care I
don't want to trade trading helps the
side that doesn't have
oh there's Queen takes Knight hmm don't
take the knight yes okay they did take
the knight oh man blunders everywhere
blunder city castle get the King out be
one before you're dead
rook on c1 Oh big trouble everything's
hit check watch out for mates making one
threat I shouldn't have done that
why'd I do that let's come back here can
recapture my rook is kind of silly on H
oh they missed that I mean to threat
they resigned back to tournament 187 142
136 one minute 18 remaining if I'm to
win this one I have to do it within 10
seconds otherwise that could always
clock burn ah man
let's go night let's go pond queenside
castle
fearing the fishing pole I'm still not
winning a piece why do I keep thinking
one piece ship just packs up the knight
takes up a post right there no it's not
now I'm on the night okay more
development so this is like I just
dropped on okay maybe six can I get this
in no night right there is gonna be
annoying no I could get okay I could
trade and then take here there is a rook
coming to this Knight right here
this game isn't gonna finish there's
only 29 seconds remaining in the
tournament can we trade a little bit
just a little bit push this pawn grab
the beep on I could give a check maybe
with my rook at some point yep that's
it's not finishing first confetti ah man
okay 187 one
86 149 149 not without a loss in a drive
oh this guy right here Totoro vaq gave
me a beating
ah man he had a silly little pond right
there a silly little pond hmm